oggi vi voglio parlare di città vi
voglio parlare città e soprattutto del
futuro che questa città possono
raggiungere nel momento in cui decidono
di superare questa stagione ambigua in
cui la politica forse ha perso sicurezza
sicuramente denaro ma anche forza ideale
in cui la stampa ai noi cerca spesso
solo notizie decotte in cui pessimisti
urlano più forte degli ottimisti
me ne voglio parlare perché io sono
invece convinto che sia in corso in
italia e non in europa una vera e
propria prima primavera urbana che fa
piazza pulita degli schemi classici e
mette pubblico e privato finalmente a
negoziare dalla stessa parte del tavolo
ci aiuta in questo una frase di
alejandro aravena voi sapete alejandro
ha vinto il premio nobel
dell'architettura del più giovane
vincitore del premio nobel per
l'architettura quest'anno alejandro al
chiude il proprio tech talk nel 2014
dicendo il potere della progettazione e
cercare di fare un uso più efficiente
delle risorse scarse nelle città e
questo non è un fatto di soldi ma di
coordinamento
ebbene io mi occupo di paesaggio urbano
ma cosa significa non significa
disegnare nuovi filari di alberi ma
cercare di ricostruire un immaginario
coordinato per fare città facendo
comunità
credo di aver capito questo una notte
esattamente una notte di 40 anni fa
pensate il 6 maggio 1976 intere città
crollavano in friuli su intere comunità
e mentre lì quella nella natura faceva
mille morti
io al tempo viveva vittorio veneto e fui
costretto a girare la città di notte a
fermarmi nei parcheggi lungo una strada
in tanti piccoli luoghi della città
ebbene quell'immaginario mi aveva fatto
capire che spesse volte città e comunità
si danno le spalle
veniamo ad oggi che cosa sta succedendo
oggi sta succedendo invece che città e
comunità hanno tre grandi moschettieri
che gli consentono di tornare insieme
il primo è la crisi lo conosciamo il
secondo una legge cometa che arriva
dall'europa legge in italia da dieci
anni ma ancora molto inascoltata si
chiama convenzione europea del paesaggio
il terzo è ovviamente una frase di
proust
la crisi ho detto la conosciamo la
seconda la legge cometa dice ad un certo
punto una frase che manda in soffitta
400 anni di storia
la frase è un paesaggio qualunque pezzo
di territorio trasformato con
consapevolezza
improvvisamente il paesaggio non è più
solo il bel paesaggio
lo aveva già detto il mondo diverso
proust tempo addietro proust aveva detto
il vero viaggio di scoperta non se non
significa andare a visitare nuove terre
ma sostanzialmente semplicemente avere
nuovi occhi
ebbene con questi tre moschettieri non
abbiamo più alibi e quindi abbiamo
capito che siamo infilati in un bertone
ma abbiamo tutti gli strumenti per poter
finalmente arredare un tunnel
veniamo ai temi di oggi a tutti voi sarà
capitato di cominciare a schiacciare
play sul mangia nastro analogico anche
immagino ai nativi digitali in sala
ebbene non era tanto il problema che
questo tasto non si riuscisse a
schiacciare quanto il fatto che sotto
casa non c'era più il negozio che poteva
aggiustar velo
nel frattempo il negozio era stato
sostituito da una rivendita di cover per
smartphone bene immaginate che alle
città stia accadendo esattamente questo
i decisori schiacciano play ma quel play
non sta più giù ci troviamo a vivere da
vintage urbani da hipster nostalgici che
cosa è accaduto
e accaduto che è venuta giù quella
babele speculativa nella quale un
impresario edile in una notte diventava
imprenditore immobiliare è accaduto che
interi quartieri avanzassero sotto i
nostri occhi con il piede gonfio
lo stesso piede gonfio di quel ministro
che se n'è andato lasciandoci una legge
sui capannoni ovunque ea un certo punto
una frase con la cultura non si mangia
potete immaginare quale fu la mia
soddisfazione di togliermi un sassolino
dalla scarpa
ma un giorno di ferragosto e di spiegare
esattamente a con l'omonimo signor t che
io non ero d'accordo con lui ma deriva
invece alla frase scusate alla frase del
grande geografo franco farinelli che
dice la cultura è l'ultimo grande
manipolatore di senso che ci resta
ebbene quella frase consentì a me
personalmente di fare due azzardi che
cambiarono integralmente la mia vita
all'incirca nel 2007 il primo
infinitamente polpi piccolo una parola
il secondo infinitamente grande un
festival il primo mi consentì di
proporre al dibattito cui già
apparteneva un termine il termine era
casa non è casa più capannone e riusciva
a descrivere molto più di qualunque di
qualunque saggio quell'epopea che aveva
trasformato il nord est negli ultimi 50
anni
quella forza mi veniva non dai soliti
libri nei quali un paesaggista si andava
a formare le città invisibili piuttosto
che le sei passeggiate nei boschi
narrativi di umberto eco mi derivava da
un carteggio tra due amici un carteggio
nel quale i due amici si scambiavano
delle cartoline con all'interno dei casi
tipologici assolutamente curiosi la
chiesa multiuso piuttosto che la campo a
casa
avevo capito la grande forza dello story
telling un secondo azzardo che feci fu
quello di lanciare in italia nel 2007 il
primo festival dedicato alle aree
dismesse una piattaforma nata dal basso
come te dx per rompere completamente
negli schemi per ibridare le discipline
è una piattaforma nella quale
improvvisamente c'era la possibilità di
realizzare degli interi giardini abusivi
c'era perfino la possibilità di mettere
il pigiama e di trasformare la piazza
centrale della città in una grande
camera da letto c'era perfino la
possibilità di portare a scala urbana
quel gesto che tutti noi almeno una
volta abbiamo fatto cioè quello di
mettere un elastico tra le mani e
cominciare a fare così bene immaginate
cosa possa accadere se questo gesto
assume la dimensione
bana accade quello che ora vedete
l'italia vista dalla luna e quindi anche
la moda in italia vista dalla luna bene
appunto l'italia vista dalla luna
io penso che l'italia sia in curva o
meglio oltre quella curva esiste già un
immaginario di città che ci consenta di
mandare in soffitta un'altra fava se
tutti noi diciamo sempre pensiamo di
capire la storia per riuscire ad agire
del presente invece io penso che oggi
noi dobbiamo capire il presente per
capire la storia abbiamo capito che
finalmente soluzione complessa e
soluzione semplice non sono più in
contraddizione tra di loro e con tutto
questo bagaglio vorrei farvi vedere due
progetti e un immaginario di progetto
che sta nascendo esattamente proprio
nella vostra città
il primo progetto che vi faccio vedere
un progetto che lanciò il più grande
investitore altotesino un grandissimo
collezionista d'arte contemporanea lui
cerca si compra il più grande magazzino
dismesso delle ferrovie dello stato che
affaccia sull'adige si immagina di poter
realizzare la sua il suo business in
brevissimo tempo ma anche lui nonostante
fosse alimentato dalle sue visioni
sbatte di fronte a quel muro di gomma
che tutti noi abbiamo vissuto almeno una
volta quel muro di gomma si chiama
burocrazia
allora che cosa bisogna fare dovevamo
trovare una mossa del cavallo mettere
una zeppa scartare appunto ci siamo
riusciti passando da un progetto a un
programma molto più complesso che
innanzitutto decidesse di accettare quel
luogo così come trovato il primo gesto
quindi significativo non fu quello di
disegnare appartamenti ma immediatamente
di fare un'operazione di questo tipo
tirare giù il muro che divideva quello
spazio dal quartiere popolare di porto
san pancrazio e di realizzare in soli
quattro giorni uno spazio da mettere a
disposizione della comunità
uno spazio che non aveva panchine che
aveva dei disegni che riprendevano
le regole dei campi del parco rurale che
ci stava di fianco uno spazio in cui
mettere in scena pezzi dell'arte
contemporanea della collezione di
quell'imprenditore nei mesi successivi
l'imprenditore fu subissato di richieste
per utilizzare questo spazio
prima di tutto dalla propria comunità
non aveva ancora realizzato un solo
appartamento
il secondo esempio che vi faccio vedere
fa riferimento a un paese nel quale
ognuno di voi almeno una volta ha
pensato dalla pensato di andarci
sto parlando di collodi il paese di
pinocchio il secondo libro più tradotto
al mondo dopo la bibbia un paese
compreso tra una valle delle cartiere
che da solo assorbe gran parte del
fabbisogno nazionale della carta in
italia e quindi è ovvio che quella
favola poteva non essere che scritta ii
ea sud una grande valle di serre dei
fiori voi vi direte con la carta e con i
fiori collodi deve essere un paese
straordinario
e invece no bugia collodi è una delle
periferie più triste e sconosciute che
voi possiate trovare perché accade
questo accade perché anche a collodi
quelle che noi chiamiamo centralità
antibiotiche i musei la piazza al
monumento dedicato a collodi che cercano
i turisti non dialoga più con le
centralità che chiamiamo omeopatiche e
che fanno e che sono parte della
quotidianità dei cittadini la discesa al
fiume
una piazza che nel frattempo è diventata
è diventata parcheggio e si è degradata
e tanti altri luoghi minori insomma
dovevamo cercare uno strumento che ci
consentisse di mettere insieme queste
due centralità lo abbiamo trovato
ridisegnando e se guardate cosa siamo
riusciti a trovare siamo riusciti a
capire che esisteva un parco più ampio
in cui centralità antibiotiche
omeopatiche si mettevano insieme e
assumevano perfino il volto di pinocchio
in cui quella che era la piazza dei
turisti in realtà diventava il centro
del paese questo bosco era in realtà un
grande palazzo verde
vorrei chiudere con
una proiezione di progetto dicevo
appunto a vicenza a vicenza abbiamo un
luogo immenso e che ormai nella bocca di
tutti ma in realtà è un luogo ancora
resta sostanzialmente sconosciuto questo
luogo noi lo chiamiamo il parco della
pace
ebbene vorrei dirvi da co progettista di
quel luogo ma anche da cittadino
acquisito in questa città da pochi anni
che non vi è dubbio che in quel luogo
oggi passino il cardo e il decumano di
una nuova comunità quella che si può
realizzare con i termini di prima questo
luogo può diventare un nuovo ai mart si
direbbe una piccola patria
tutto sta nel saper veicolare diciamo
questa forza bene grazie a questi
progetti io credo a questo punto di aver
capito di proporre a voi questa cosa
l'ibridazione dei saperi rappresenta un
giacimento è limitato da cui estrarre
nuove città e nuovi paesaggi
tutto però dipende da quanto la comunità
cioè voi e noi decide di tornare al
centro della scena
grazie